For Kelly Marathon with Dungham, Day 1,
2, 3, allegation.
Allegation basically means
a public statement that is made
without giving any proof,
accusing that someone has done something
wrong or illegal.
There are some examples. Number one,
several newspapers have made
allegations of corruption in the city's police
department. No. 2,
amid allegations of dishonesty against him,
he fled the country to Africa. And No. 3,
he is quite untrustworthy,
as there have been several allegations
that he had been dishonest.
There are some synonyms of allegation,
which are accusation,
charge, claim,
plea and statement.
Last but not least,
the Vietnamese meaning of allegation is cowboy
souvingly vinca.
That's it. Like and subscribe,
and I'll see you tomorrow.